Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas is
in Janine for the first time in more
than 10 years
it comes days after a major Israeli
assault on the city's refugee camp in
the occupied West Bank
these olives we planted and we protect
and we maintain and if they cut a tree
we will plant in its place a thousand
trees this is Palestine and this is the
Palestinian people
dear brothers I'd like to tell you that
the authority and the state has come
here to emphasize its support for the
Janine camp and our people in the city
the Palestinian Authority is a United
Authority and one nation with one law
security and stability I would like to
say for all people far and near we
remain as one nation and anybody trying
to mess around with our Unity will face
nothing but bad consequences we would
not allow and we will not accept it all
and I say this loudly and frankly any
external hand that tries to approach our
unity and our security and peace and
stability we will cut the hand this
country wants to remain United all of us
united we are working together to remain
together on our land until we liberate
this Homeland
yeah let's go to Alan Fisher who is live
in Janine for us in the occupied West
Bank Alan so I believe Mahmoud Abbas
still in Janine talk us through the
visit so far
well the message of unity there from
Mahmoud Abbas he was here just two hours
ago just after he landed you can see the
wreath that he left in the new graveyard
that is being built because the two
graveyards that were here in Janine are
now full up that's because this year
alone that 64 people have been killed in
gene including the 11 that are buried
there who died during the Israeli
assault Just A Week Ago 12 people died
in total 11 of them are buried over
there and we heard from Mahmoud Abbas
talking about unity and how there would
be a rebuilding project here and you can
see the need for rebuilding you can see
the damage that has been done that's
just some of the rubble that has been
cleared in the past week but clearly
there are areas like this all over
Janine just negotiating your way here
we're to take several different roads to
try and find a way that was clear and
he's promised that the money that has
been pledged by the United Arab Emirates
and also Algeria will be used to rebuild
Janine to make it better than it was
before it's estimated that they'll need
somewhere in the mid the region of 15.5
million dollars to do that rebuild but
as he leaves and he'll leave probably
just in the next 10-15 minutes or so
he's currently meeting with the the
authorities here in Janine people will
want to see if his words of unity and
his promise of rebuilding will actually
be delivered whether or not they will
actually see a difference in their
everyday lives which is what most people
just want from politicians because there
is a high level of dissatisfaction with
the Palestinian Authority which is why
he talked about Unity he's aware of what
happened last week at the funerals when
a leading member of fata Mahmoud
abbasa's party was asked to leave the
funeral people feel disappointed they
feel neglected by the Palestinian
Authority they feel that they are
targets here in Janine and there was a
security alert for Mahmoud Abbas himself
just a few hours before he was due here
there has been a huge Security operation
in the town hundreds of Palestinian
policemen on duty all over at this
refugee camp they were on the outskirts
of the camp when an Israeli military
Convoy came towards them several
Vehicles the Palestinians put their
vehicles in the road to block their way
and essentially told them that they had
to leave but the pilot the Israelis knew
that Mahmoud Abbas was going to be here
so many in the Palestinian Authority
think that was i i a calculated snub for
him as he's here talking about unity and
trying to bring the Palestinians
together under the idea that there is
this resoluteness among them this
Defiance among them and that they will
not be moved from from areas like Janine
and the Janine refugee camp
Alan Fisher there for us and Janine in
the occupied West Bank thank you